good evening my name is John horn I'm
the host of the frame on KPCC thank you
all for coming out on behalf of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences and KPCC I want to welcome you
to this special in-person screening of
Pan's Labyrinth and this evening is made
possible through the generosity of the
California Arts Council we have an
amazing panel of filmmakers I want to
bring them up let's start with let's see
producer Barton Navarro
oscar-winning cinematographer Guillermo
Navarro
actor Ivana Picaro
actor Doug Jones
and Guillermo is gonna be a true movie
star and make his entrance so we'll go
ahead and start without him I'm sure
he's gonna join us in just a second I'm
gonna go back to about ten years ago and
I think it's really important that this
film is a centerpiece of of Latin
American and Latino art Los Angeles
because ten years ago 11 years ago this
movie comes out it becomes the
highest-grossing spanish-language movie
of all time it wins three Academy Awards
and it's still the number five highest
grossing foreign language film of all
time so I want you to go back to that
year when this film came out and what
this film represented and what it meant
to Latino filmmakers in the United
States well I think it's I saw it again
it is important there's the movie stars
entrance the cinematographer it's it's a
film that was shown all over the world
and it's persons was very very important
and I think now it's a classic actually
and I don't know but we it was well it's
there and and for me it's when the
opportunity to make this film was so
important in my life
and well it's there and I hope new
generations can see it and and I don't
think it it time doesn't it doesn't do
anything wrong it ages like a very good
bottle of wine Guillermo people who
worked with Guillermo del Toro know that
he keeps amazing notebooks and those
notebooks are filled with amazing
sketches of characters and colors and
ideas that he has for his films but it's
one thing to write something in a nope
and it's another thing to turn that into
a motion picture so when you were first
talking with the guillermo del toro
about this film what did he show you in
his notebooks and how did you translate
that into a language visually for this
film that notebook is really like like
an opening to a portal in its it's
really conceptual it's nothing to do
with storyboarding or anything like that
it's their images that that somehow we
know where they're gonna be part of that
universe and that's not only that's also
the spaces and symbols and in all this
is really like material like the clay
that you have to work with and something
that it's very that was very important
for us in this movie was that from the
get-go we have to bring the audience in
a comfortable space where that parallel
reality was there it was familiar we to
just step in and out of it and for that
we had to build a language a visual
language were the the girl of failure
the grown-up here could easily walk in
and out of that parallel reality so we
were able to build bridges that for that
we had to take the risks of going in
doing things that were artificial in a
way but that allowed all this craziness
to be long so for instance we had things
like in the camera truck there was a
piece of trunk which was a tree that was
that we were able to go in and sweep by
it and then we would be in one place or
the other or or the ability to have a
color palette that would make no sense
because the world outside is coal in the
world inside it's warm in the world of
other free other fighters is warm and of
the way
it's warm in the military world is cold
etc it said there were many things to be
catching up with so it does start with
that conceptual world but then its
ingredients to build with it
navona when Guillermo was casting this
film he was looking for a younger girl
maybe age 8 or 9 and you came in much
much older at the age of 10 I thank for
your audition and you did the film when
you were 11 could you do you remember
back to that first meeting with
Guillermo because I think he looked
almost a thousand actors before he cast
this part yeah I mean as we were
discussing with Berta before the movie
to some extent I think changed
everyone's life in one way or another in
this movie it obviously changed my life
so much it opened so many doors but yeah
I remember that first time I had
actually started acting when I was 8 so
right before Pan's Labyrinth when I was
about 11 years old I got a manager for
the first time ever and he was the one
who brought me the audition for Pan's
Labyrinth and I remember going in and I
had these sides but then Guillermo
looked at me and he said oh but it's
this other scene that we need you to do
so can you just quickly memorize it
everything to perform so there I was
like about 10 years old and and I did it
and he really enjoyed it and then I got
a callback and I went and again and that
was a pretty emotional scene in fact it
was the scene where I'm talking to the
mums belly towards the end of the movie
and I'm telling my brother that you know
things are hard in the real world so he
really enjoyed the scene I remember his
wife was there too and she was bawling
her eyes out and that day is the day
where he actually came to me and he
offered me the role with this script in
hand and I was like 11 years old but it
was you know it was it was the beginning
of truly a very magical journey so the
lesson is if you can make the directors
wife cry during the audition we're
probably in pretty good shape
Doug how many films have you made with
the how many films have you made with
Guillermo at that point when you when
you did this film before this I'd done
mimic and and the first Hellboy movie
also with you on the Varro here who our
cinematographer so the ipad's not with
number three for me but now I sit here
today with a total of six movies with
him under my belt including the recent
shape of water I know yes you will see
Doug and all of his amphibian beauty in
shape of water in a couple of weeks when
he talks to you about playing the faun
and pale man does he have a design for
you and what does that design mean in
terms of what it means physically in
terms of your transformation of how much
time it's actually gonna take you to get
into this get up bright right he never
tells me how much long it's gonna take I
have to find out on the day the Fond
took me about five hours to get into
makeup and the pale man was about six
hours a day and those the makeup artist
the oscar-winning makeup artist when a
DDT affect us especially Ceyda Marty and
Muncie or Ebay Gore oh there's the
dearest people and so incredibly
talented the making these creatures come
to come to beyond me but but
transforming a human a tall skinny goofy
human into a faun or a or a man with no
eyes in his hands i it takes it takes
finding it in here and then going
through the makeup process and the tests
and all so much to discover what he said
to me about the faun specifically he
only gave me a couple of notes we have a
shorthand now del Toro and I just say a
couple things like Oh got it he said
with the faun
he said boogie I want you to I was
studying a back-end of barn animals like
like cows goats you know how do their
hooves meet the ground and and they
shake flies off so you know I'll work it
in I got it so if you saw me coming do
that a couple times that was from that
note the the other note that he gave me
was that the faun would be aging
backwards if you happened right notice
every time you see everybody are in
prettier gets prettier and more a burn
colored and his horns grow back and his
eyes clear up as the movie progresses
because little Ophelia starts believing
in me again and in our world and that
strengthens the whole the whole
underworld yeah
it's so weird to see you've grown up the
this one of the sad twists of the story
is that you were in makeup for five or
six hours while you're learning Spanish
right well there's the other part of
that story okay we're trying to learn
Spanish what no I I went off one offered
this part I read the script in English
wiped a tear away close the last pages
that I have to be of course yes thank
you and then I saw the email that said
it's gonna be in the Spanish language I
I don't speak Spanish and I told him I'm
going to ruin your movie and you really
have made a horrible mistake know what
actor would say that by the way and he's
and any what he said to me was nope
you're the only one who can play the
phone you can count the ten for all I
care I'll double hurt later but you
aren't playing the phone so that's so I
couldn't leave him with counting to ten
I couldn't leave you with counting to
ten in front we have we played those
scenes so I did actually buckle down and
learn that learned the language of the
film
I don't know Spanish on the street but I
did know the language of this film i I
studied that I had my English and
Spanish translations and knew knew what
was happening all along so that was I
was at boy I was the hardest thing I've
ever done in my life
Guillermo there is a
there is not a lot of dialogue in this
film the language of the film is visual
and it's visual through camera moves and
it's visual through color so what does
that mean in terms of your conversations
with Guillermo del Toro about how are
you gonna tell the narrative this film
when there isn't very much dialogue and
what does that mean in terms of your
responsibilities and your department and
how they're gonna tell this story with
very little narrative dialogue to drive
it well it's all about film language so
it's the story told with images and that
it's a camera that is looking that is
searching and it's finding and it's
their entire scenes that are just images
one of the most you know one of the icon
scenes is the film and in it's one shot
after the other in in finding that that
language is it's not something that you
just execute there's there's a whole
process of every movie that we've done
together has a language that serves the
purpose of that movie is not that we
have a recipe hitting or or you know in
our backpack we have the solution so it
is a very complex in nice process where
there's there's also are very important
let's say it's not a rule but it's like
a statement we want to make that we
don't we don't do coverage there's not
such thing as the over and the over and
the close-up of the closer within the
reverse at the master and none of that
the only scene in this movie that
required a little bit of that is the
scene where there where the captain is
is and the dinner and the table because
everybody's stationary and even there we
managed by moving their mother and
excusing herself to to move the camera
but it's really the rule is find the
shot take all the chances in allow the
visuals to tell the story there there's
other things that I just remember when I
saw the movie again it's there were
there were incredible limitations that
we had on location and I just remember
this for instance we have
we we couldn't afford to do all all the
night pert for nights we have a lot of
words in speak spaces etc so I would say
that a very strong percentage of the
nights are day for nights so you just
shoot with lower I'm not gonna tell you
how okay no secret shared here at the
academy
okay I could tell you but you're
shooting day for night yes some of it
but but for that you you have to have a
reference of what a night for night is
and then that night were night has to be
treated with certain artificiality so
the first opportunity in the movie for
that is when they go out of state and he
kills the peasants so that is that night
for night reference of the moon and then
from there on everything is to be
serviced all that although scenes in the
river when they're on the way to the
guerrilla camp it's a fair there you see
spots of Sun but at this point in the
movie you have completely swallowed that
there's parallel realities and nothing
necessarily is real for real actually we
want you to believe that is this her
imagination is this really happening
it's not can we really go in different
borders and cross avenues like that and
then this movie teaches us yes for that
you have to allow the language to get
you but at least there is also a
tremendous amount of real violence in
this film real violence there are some
real it's it's it's a movie against
fascism I know that I think we should be
a little bit aware of what's going on
and we're aware of that
so when you're when you're making love
you're with me or against me but are you
talking as you're making the film about
it being a parable a fairy tale a
political allegory what are the
conversations that you're having about
what this film is because it's not
always what it seems well it's it's all
that it's a very big picture it's also
for Mexico for instance the the
experience of a Spanish Civil War
it represents a lot so we were we were
the country that received the Spanish
exile so we were very we were very in
touch with what that drama was so that's
the Spanish ship what role is that
double tragedy where the Allies didn't
go to Spain they were left behind they
were untouched so all this is what but
with this movies about so movie against
fascism it's again it's a movie against
sharing a vision of that there are
things to be done then you have to live
the way that your life the way you want
to live and you have to live your life
and you have to disobey and you have to
find ways to to to go about it
Ivana when you are acting there are a
lot of things that are probably present
in front of you like Doug in his five
and six hour makeup and they're probably
lot of things that aren't like fairies
flying about your visual effects so how
does Guillermo direct you and it's a
young actor what does he tap into in
terms of your imagination to get a
performance that looks as if you're
reacting to things that really aren't in
the shot at all
actually had a lot of fun doing all the
green screens there was actually a lot
of you know green screen elements and as
I was watching the movie again I I was
you know recalling all of those moments
I do have to stay obviously Doug and a
lot of things were real the toad was
real too the fairies were not for
instance but for me there was always
they always have an an element of
something real so that I could kind of
follow it with my eyes
so in that regard it wasn't that
challenging and I remember you know when
I had the grape and the fairies were
pulling the grape Guillermo came to me
and he taught me exactly how he wanted
me to do that so I had really specific
references Guillermo was always there
you know giving me very very specific
and meticulous directions and I think he
did that with everyone like even just
you know how to walk how to breathe all
of those things so so you know props to
him essentially for for all of those you
know all of those things had it not been
for him probably it wouldn't have you
come out as you know specific and
realistic duck this seems like a very
basic question but how do you actually
see when you're walking around a set and
your costume are you actually able to
navigate around well there's another
challenge well I had a hard time on this
movie you guys the faun eyes were set
pretty wide and so I was looking through
through the tear duct area so that was a
little tiny triangle here and here
zero periphery to see so I was just
looking straight ahead it's like it's
like ah there she is so right and I was
also seven feet tall in my hoof feet and
Ivana was two feet exactly so our height
difference was ridiculous so but yeah
make up seven feet tall and make him
crouched into the frame with every game
every shot was like get lower lower
lower look got it okay got it
so exactly so that was a toughy and then
the pale man of course was another issue
the eyeballs and the hands didn't really
work so spoiler I know sorry to ruin
that one for you and Santa Claus isn't
real
oh come on so so if you notice on the
pale man's face the nostrils were rather
high and large so I kind of could look
through that nostril but that eye and
that nostril of that eye so it was like
Oh coming out of that thing a day I was
like oh my eyes readjusting was like so
I could you hear because I remember your
ears moved and you had a little you had
a motor right about motors and I had if
your could you hear them when they're
going because the top half of my face
was puppeteered by dahveed in Muncie and
so because the it was thick enough and I
operated the bottom part this was all
glued to my mouth and so you saw me
actually doing the talking
but the eyes and the eyebrows and the
squinting and all that was puppeteered
the ears flapping puppeteered that was
all motors servos in your head while
you're trying to listen to an 11-year
old girl like as he's speaking Spanish
right oh oh it was hard you guys
[Laughter]
it looks good though Berta I want to ask
you about the making of this movie
because it's no secret that Guillermo
had a very difficult time making mimic
with Miramax and he wanted to make this
film independently he didn't want to
make it with a studio and he wanted make
it in Spanish and he want to make it in
Spain so what does that mean in terms of
putting together the financing in a
production and getting your locations
because he doesn't want this to be an
American studio film even though Warner
Brothers and picturehouse end up
distributing it well I think that the
story was really in Spanish and and also
I think that we did these three films
and we did Espinosa in the era there was
perfect back home before so you did have
a connection with Spain and at that
moment it was very important to do Pan's
Labyrinth and so we we did go with with
[Music]
Telecinco and we financed it completely
in with tequila gang and Telecinco and I
think that also these films that the
three films I did with him that's Kronos
and Devil's Backbone and Pan's Labyrinth
the three of them are told or through
the eyes and through the yes through the
eyes of a child and that also I think
the child within
[Music]
Guillermo he he has saved that child to
create this this worlds you know if it
wasn't through the through even through
that child it would have been impossible
really
to believe in all these fantasy now so I
am I'm very close and we we had worked
together I knew exactly what he wanted
and he needed that profound
collaboration with Guillermo and with
all the people who worked with but
basically organic about you know also he
did a great job and we end up he is I
think his his work is amazing and and
the actors I think are great so it is an
authentic Spanish film absolutely oh man
and we should say too that Guillermo did
the subtitles himself because he wasn't
happy with the way his own film was
translated so he did the subtitles
himself I'm gonna have one last quote
for the actors but I won't talk about
the sound design because I think the
sound design for this film is
unbelievable and I think if you listen
closely to the creatures and the doors
and everything in this film it really
suggests what a master of sound gear I'm
always and I think you can hear it
you're not in your head doug is that was
that something that was really important
to him in the making of this film that
the sound design be as good as
everything else it feels that way even
even like when when Ivonne I picked up
my eyeballs and you could hear them
going on the plate it was like ok yeah
every little teach detail yeah and
oftentimes in a lot of his films he
tends to do a voice or to himself so I
don't know if those fairies were him
pitched up or not it's worth
investigating ever I think he did the
voice of the Frog is that right I'll
think yeah I think he did a Vaughn I
know you were a very young actor when
you made this film watching it again
tonight what do you remember about the
making of it what fond memories do you
have when you watch it again I remember
everything
I think obviously it was it was such an
intense experience it was pretty much
like going to acting school in those
three months I learned so much and I had
to watch the movie so many times
because of the promotion and because we
were lucky enough to go to all these
festivals that I really have a vivid
memory of everything even of you know
the process of developing Ophelia of all
the conversations with Guillermo there's
a few moments that that are nice to kind
of you know reminiscence and remember
but but I have I I really do remember
everything and and it always makes me
cry it always does no matter how many
times I watched it I was there too but
yeah right I know usually you know when
we do a Q&A of past labyrinths it's
usually before the film and it's the
first time I actually had to do one
after the film and I was like I don't
know busted this film was very important
for all of you and your careers so
before we leave your next doing shape of
water with Guillermo is that right that
is correct that comes out December 8th
and theaters everywhere and thank you as
as well as as well as I'm current
currently playing lieutenant commander
Saru in Star Trek discovery and Ivana
what about you okay I'm currently
shooting a show called the shannara
chronicles' and the second season is
airing on Spike TV at the moment yeah
Moe what's next for you I've continued
shooting movies I started directing some
television I just finished directing my
first feature and that I shot two
and now I'm gonna go to London for seven
months to shoot dr. Dolittle oh my
goodness and Berta outside of making
sure your brother doesn't get into too
much trouble what are you up to well I
keep on working and I just finished
shooting a film in sonatas desert I'm a
little crazy at my age but I was there
so I still hope to do more films and and
well but the opportunity to do these
three things with Guillermo del Toro and
with Guillermo was amazing I want to
thank the 700 people who came out
tonight to watch this movie and I want
to thank the people who made it dawg
Ivana Guillermo Berta thank you for
bringing us your film thank you have a
good
[Applause]
you